65% FREE THROW SHOOTER.
WE REMEMBER THE WORDS OF COACH
CHRIS FINCH A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
TALKING ABOUT JARRED AND HE SAYS
HE HAS TO BE THE HARDEST WORKER
ON THE TEAM.
ZY WORKER HAS FALLEN AND YOU CAN
SEE RIGHT NOW -- I'M NOT SURE IF
SHE FAINTED OR FELL, BUT THEY
ARE ASSISTING HER.
AND OUT SHE GOES.
I SAY IT WAS A WORKER, IT MAICHB
SOMEONE ELSE BECAUSE THEY
QUICKLY GOT HER UP AND GOT HER
OFF IN A HURRY.
>> Reggie: IF SHE FELL, IS THERE
BLOOD DOWN THERE?
>> Kevin: OH, OKAY.
I THINK WE'VE BEEN TOLD IT WAS A
PROTEST AND I THINK SHE WAS
WRITING SOMETHING ON THE FLOOR.
MAYBE IT WAS.
I'VE SEEN SO MANY REGGIE MILLER
WENDY'S COMMERCIALS, I DON'T
KNOW IF I WANT TO SEE ANY MORE.
>> PROBABLY WRITING BACONATOR.
>> WHATEVER IT WAS, SHE IS GONE
AND THE GRAFFITI OR WHATEVER SHE
WAS DOING ON THE FLOOR IS BEING
WIPED OFF.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE THE NBA
PLAYOFF GAME.
THIS IS NOT THE PLAYOFF, IT'S A
PLAY-IN.
>> Reggie: I'M GOING WITH A
PLAYOFF GAME.
>> Kevin: BUT THE PLAYOFF GAMES
ARE RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
YOU CAN BE LIVE, YOU CAN BE
THERE AND SECURE YOUR SEATS AT
NBCTICKET.COM.
ALLY, WHAT DO YOU SEE DOWN
THERE?
WHAT WAS GOING ON?
>> I WAS JUST TOLD BY SECURITY
THAT SHE APPARENTLY HAD GLUED
AND SHE GLUED HERSELF TO THE
FLOOR, AND SHE REFUSED TO LIFT
HER WRIST UP, AND I DON'T MEAN
TO LAUGH, BUT THIS REALLY
HAPPENED.
SHE GLUED HER WRIST TO THE FLOOR
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO PULL HER
OFF AND SHE WAS RESISTING,
TRYING TO KEEP HER WRIST GLUED
DOWN ON THE FLOOR.
>> Kevin: IT WAS A PROTEST OF
SOME SORT, I'M ASSUMING, ALLY?
>> I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
ASSUMPTION.
I'LL GET SOME CLARIFICATION OR
MAYBE WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IT
AGAIN, DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
ANSWER IS.
>> Kevin: I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
>> Reggie: IT'S A FIRST FOR ME
AND I'VE BEEN AROUND THE GAME
CLOSE TO 30 YEARS.